What is the difference between tumor cells and cancer cells? Is there a difference?
You've touched on this on many, many Zoom calls. There really is no difference.
It's old terminology. What's a tumor? What's a cancerous tumor? What's just cancer? How's there a difference?
It's hard when there's been decades and decades of medicine and terminology used in the practice of medicine.
And updated terminology is still used, but then the old terminology is used everywhere. It's interchangeable.
So, or is a tumor benign, or is it malignant? Well, it depends on what adjective you put in front of it.
So, when you say cancer, then you always know that's a malignant disease. If you say tumor, then you have to know what adjective you put in front of it.
Is it a malignant tumor? Is it benign tumor? It's semantics.
People who say stay away from animal protein, can they use collagen? Maybe, maybe not.
So, we test for that if we think the person should be able to use collagen or not.
If you're a hardcore vegan, then you're not taking collagen.
But if you're only taking away from animal protein because you have cancer and animal protein can feed the cancer, then typically not.
You could use collagen. But if you're stayed away from animal protein for some moral ethical reason, then you would probably stay away from collagen as well.
So, cancer, no, you're probably safe with collagen.